ما تقييمك لهذه الانتخابات بعد اقفال
مراكز الاقتراع وبدء فرز الاصوات
كما شاهدت اليوم ايضا حين توجهت انا لكي
اقتنع فان المشاركه سجلت مستوى مرتفعا
اكثر من 90% كما افادت بعد التقارير حتى
بالنسبه الى تركيا فهذا رقم قياسي وهذا
يظهر ان الحزبين اي تحالف الموالاه وتحالف
المعارضه
هما فعلا طموحان
وعينه كل منهما على الفوز عاده يكون ذلك
طبيعيا ولكن في تركيا هذه هي المره الاولى
بحسب تجربتي
التي ارى فيها المعارضه متفائله جدا
بالفوز لانه من قبل كان الجميع اكيدا انه
لدينا قائد
محبوب وشعبي الرئيس اردوغان وانه هو سوف
يفوز
توقع الجميع ان يفوز فوزا ساحقا ولكن هذه
اصعب انتخابات يواجهوها اردوغان في اخر 20
عاما وربما هذا احد الاسباب التي راينا
فيها المشاركه مرتفعه ونسبه الاقتراع
عاليه لان من يناصر رئيس اردوغان يقترع
ومن يرغب في تغيير
القياده في تغيير
الطبقه الحاكمه ايضا يرى في هذه الفرصه
فرصه سانحه من اجل الاقتراع في محاوله
للتغيير اذن
اعتقد اننا سوف نرى بعد ساعتين او ثلاث
ساعات نتائج الاوليه سوف تبدا بالظهور
لان الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
تاخذ وقتها بعد الثامنه سوف تبدا
النتائج ولكن احيانا قد تتركوا لي
الاذاعات والقنوات ان تبث النتائج في
قرابه السابع لا نعرف السابعه او الثامنه
مساء بتوقيت المحلي في تركيا ولكن الان
بحسب ما ورد على موقع التواصل هناك الكثير
من المعلومات التي تتبادلها الناس ولكن
بالنسبه الى النتائج اعتقد اننا سوف نسمع
رقما حاسما بعد العاشره او 11 مساء
عاليه قد يكون هناك اعتراض على فرز
الاصوات
والكثير من
الاحزاب او بعد التحالفات قد تطلب اعاده
الفرز او اعاده عدد الاصوات هذا امر نتوقع
هذا ليس امرا غريبا على تركيا